hell gray is so much better than english
breakfast what's up guys my name is the
churno welcome back to the ray tracing
series today we're going to be talking
all about cameras and specifically
implementing a camera system into our
existing ray tracing code this over here
being able to move with wasd keys and
rotate the camera with the mouse this is
what we'll be achieving here today now
this kind of camera system that we'll be
implementing here is going to be
virtually identical to the kind of
camera setup you would have for an
actual real-time kind of rasterized
graphics application so if we take a
look at any game engine like unity or
unreal or hazel the way that we'll be
making our camera system work within our
ray tracing project is going to be it's
going to be the same kind of camera
because we are technically sending out
rays there are some shortcuts that we
can take i mean we've been taking one
already if you take a look at the code
that we're running at the moment you
know we're able to generate these kinds
of coordinates and sure like they're not
tied exactly to an aspect ratio but
that's also pretty easy to do if we
break down these components into like
the math like what we're actually doing
by shooting rays out into all of these
different directions
it's honestly pretty simple and probably
doesn't require any
any super
advanced math unless you're trying to do
something super precise which
i mean we we will be remember the
fundamental camera system is basically
just a position
so where is the camera in the world
right is it here is it there because
that's obviously going to define what
the camera sees
that is what we refer to as the ray
origin but then there's also obviously
where the camera is pointing is it
pointing that way is it pointing that
way just knowing where it is in the
world isn't really enough because we
need to know which way it's facing and
that is what our array direction is now
at the moment inside our code base we
basically have a fixed ray origin which
is zero zero one so we've translated our
camera by one unit along the z axis and
then we have array direction which is
simply in the negative z direction so
facing backwards compared to where we
moved it to and then across some kind of
defined field of view but really that
field of view is going to be between
like negative one and one because that's
the coordinate that we're actually
passing in over here using this method
we don't have an easy way to rotate the
camera and we also don't have an easy
way to adjust the field of view and the
field of view is basically what
determines what kind of lens we actually
have on our camera is it like a wide 18
millimeter lens is it a super like
telephoto 200 millimeter lens we
probably want to be able to control that
and if we get into like super physically
based aspects in this series in the
future which we might then we would
potentially want to like be able to
customize the sensor size so how big is
this kind of light sensor that's
capturing all of this light because
that's also going to determine the field
of view effectively as is the actual
lens that we can set so instead of
setting like a vertical field of view of
like 45 degrees or something we can
maybe chuck on like a 50 millimeter lens
on this ray tracing like application and
then see like a realistic render from a
50 millimeter lens with an appropriate
aperture with an appropriate depth of
field relating to that aperture i mean
you know the possibilities are endless
but anyway the main kind of goal of the
camera system that we'll be implementing
here today is the ability to actually
interact with the camera so i want to be
able to like move the camera around use
the mouse to like be able to rotate it i
want to be able to interact with this
application because obviously we can see
that it's running in real time anyway
it's like six or so milliseconds per
frame on this hardware we should just be
able to fly around it as if it was just
a normal rasterized like renderer and
that is exactly what we'll be doing here
today now i already took the time to
write the majority of this camera system
this is the ray tracing series camera
systems and input handling and all of
that aren't really related to rendering
so i didn't want to waste too much time
in this series talking about that but we
will go over what i've already written
and we will have to integrate it into
our existing code base as well as always
though if you're not understanding all
the math in this series and want to go a
little bit more deeply then i highly
recommend you check out the sponsor of
this series brilliant brilliant is a
website filled with amazing courses on
various stem topics and their large
collection of math topics is absolutely
brilliant forgive the pun all of the
math that we'll be using in this series
from linear algebra all the way to
calculus they cover all of it and unlike
other course platforms their courses are
extremely engaging interactive and
visual instead of just making you watch
videos and maybe giving you exercises
brilliant will actively quiz you after
like each section and present everything
to you in a visual interactive form so
that you can like play with the math and
see the results of that it is absolutely
the best way to learn all of this stuff
learning it without any kind of visual
aid can be extremely challenging aside
from math they've also got a large
collection of other courses on topics
such as computer science data structures
artificial intelligence the best thing
about brilliant is that you can get
started for free just go to
brilliant.org the churno that link will
be in the description below and you can
get started right now but if you do like
it brilliant have also been nice enough
to offer the first 200 of my subscribers
20 off an annual membership using that
link in the description below so
definitely check that out huge thank you
as always to brilliant for sponsoring
this video so i have this camera.h and
camera.cpp file these have been written
using walnuts existing api but i've
added some things to walnut which is the
underlying framework for this ray
tracing application so make sure that
you pull the latest wallnaut code if you
are writing this on your own and these
two files are obviously going to be part
of the commit for this episode on the
raytracing github repository so that's
where you can grab these files i'm going
to copy them and coming into the
solution explorer over here if i just go
to the main folder of our ray tracing
series let's go into source and then i'm
just going to paste them right over here
if i go back a couple of directories
i should just be able to run the
setup.bat script and now it will
regenerate the project file which will
mean that the camera.h and camera cpp
files are here by the way as a little
side note if you're not sure how to
update a git sub module all you have to
do is go into the directory of the sub
module and because it's a sub module
that kind of is a git repository in and
of itself so if we just open a command
prompt inside this directory all we have
to do is type in git pull origin master
to just get the latest master branch
from the remote repository and that's it
you can see that it's pulled the latest
walnut code and then once that's done
you'll have to rerun setup.bat to
regenerate the walnut vcx project and
all that with the latest code as well
because there have been some files that
have been added now if we go back into
here and we reload everything let's take
a look at the camera class so we have
this header file and this cpp file i've
tried to be relatively clean like with
this api so that it makes sense this is
moderately based off of hazel's camera
system however i've simplified it quite
a lot i've opted for kind of like an
unreal engine style camera i guess unity
has this as well i think where you can
just hold right click and then move the
mouse to rotate and then while you're
holding right click you can also use
wasd keys to fly around so it's kind of
like a first person camera rather than
like an orbiting camera and my major
kind of reason for doing that is because
on laptops without like a middle mouse
button i find that kind of camera is
really easy to use if you if all you
have is like a trackpad so hopefully
this will be good for most people now
using this class is pretty simple it
just takes in a vertical field of view
this is in degrees probably important to
specify that and then we also have a
near clip and a far clip plane now these
refer to basically the near and far
clipping planes of what our camera can
see because what happens is essentially
like a frosting will be created out of
this field of view and these near clip
and far clip planes and anything outside
of that frostum will be clipped it won't
be rendered now without getting too deep
into this the reason why it will get
clipped is because eventually we're
going to take all of this like data and
convert it into that negative one-to-one
space that we've been dealing with
anyway and anything outside of that
space just simply will not end up on the
screen so it works that way both for
rasterized graphics and also over here
inside our ray tracing project we have
to call on update every frame with the
time step this is what's going to enable
us to move around at like a constant
speed that is independent of frame rate
on resize is going to be important as
well because we'll have to recalculate
our projection matrix and then we have a
bunch of getters for various details of
this camera that we might want to access
like the projection the inverse
projection the view the inverse view the
position of the camera as well as a
directional vector of where it's
pointing then we have something a little
bit interesting which is get ray
directions in a minute we're going to
take a look at the implementation of
this and there is some decently heavy
math that needs to be done in order to
convert like all of our cameras
projection matrices and view matrix and
all that stuff into actual ray
directions and into that kind of
negative one-to-one space that i talked
about earlier now doing this on the cpu
especially single threaded and
potentially without ssd instructions i
don't need to take a look at if glm's
configured to do that at the moment but
it can be fairly slow
eventually when we move this stuff onto
the gpu
this is going to be so negligible that
there's just not going to be any dent
really in like the matrix math the
matrix multiplication map for example
that we'll need to do in a minute here
however i found that on the cpu single
threaded the math does take like a few
milliseconds per frame just to calculate
this stuff which is why what i've done
here is i've just cached the ray
directions they still do need to be
recalculated every time the camera moves
however if you're not moving then you'll
just be able to use the cache directions
and it will be much faster then we also
have a rotation speed this might be
useful if you want to like adjust your
mouse sensitivity which just this
doesn't exactly support but we could
easily add it okay and then we have a
bunch of variables obviously so getting
into the meat of this let's take a look
at how it works so initially we just set
up the direction the position to these
arbitrary values which is kind of
similar to what we were using we had
negative one i think and one this is
just zoomed out a little bit more i
think the reason why i ended up setting
it to three is just because uh the field
of view that we pass in depending on
what you pass in that's going to
obviously dictate how like zoomed in you
are so
therefore like how far back you'll have
to move the camera to compensate for
like using a longer lens if that makes
sense that's going to be dependent
obviously on the field of view that you
pass in you can technically measure the
field of view if you wanted to and be
like okay that's how many that's how
much i want to see like you know in
meters this far away from the camera but
we're not going to bother with that okay
so on update is basically going to grab
the delta of the mouse now this is
effectively the sensitivity which i've
just arbitrarily set to 0.002 i think
that's what it's set to in hazel as well
it's going to subtract the current mouse
position from the last mouse position so
the mouse position from the previous
frame this is going to give us a delta
of how much the mouse has actually moved
in the course of one frame we need to
make sure that we're constantly updating
this so that our last mouse position is
accurate but otherwise if the right
mouse button is not pressed then we just
return right because this camera is only
active if we're actually holding that
right mouse button so if it's not
pressed we want to make sure we return
the cursor mode to normal and return
otherwise we're going to lock the cursor
now what this does is basically locks
your cursor to the window so that you
basically can't really move the cursor
you can still get the delta but when you
unlock it you'll find the cursor in the
same position that it was before and it
also hides the cursor which as you'll
see will be quite nice when we want to
move around the camera and not like look
at the locked cursor then we have a
little moved flag so that we can tell
whether or not we need to recalculate
those ray directions and also the
matrices we're calculating a right
direction so what is like you know if
our camera is facing this way what is
the right directional vector from our
camera we're doing that by just crossing
our forward directional vector with our
up vector here and actually reading this
code i'm realizing that since i also
have up direction i might as well just
use that here but basically what that
will do is grab the up direction of the
vector which i wish i had a pen here so
we have this directional vector that's
facing up that's going to be 0 1 0 so 1
on the y axis and if we cross that with
a forward vector we're going to get a
vector facing that way and that's going
to be our right direction and that of
course is something that we'll be using
here in a minute now up direction is
self-explanatory that's just a vector
pointing up now because we don't support
tilting here it's always going to be
that if we did support tilting so kind
of rotating along the z-axis then we
would have to also calculate the up
direction but otherwise it's a lot
easier obviously to just set it to 1 on
the y-axis we have an arbitrary speed
here which should be adjustable and then
we have basically all of our movement
based on the input so if we press the w
key to go forward we simply are going to
add to the position our forward
direction now i i'm actually going to
rewrite a bit of this code now that i'm
looking at it because this was very very
hasty with my writing of this and i
don't really like the way that i play
this out what i'm going to do is just
quickly change it while explaining it to
be more like this and the reason being
is that
the forward direction is the main thing
we're adding right so i want that to be
the first thing we're looking at and
then speed is a multiplier that goes on
to forward direction and then really
everything has to be multiplied by the
time step so that we scale it
appropriately depending on how fast our
program is running so in my opinion like
this is a much cleaner way of writing it
because you can clearly see okay you're
taking position and you're adding
forward direction and the rest is kind
of like whatever they just modifiers on
that vector let's go ahead and change
that everywhere okay so obviously the w
key moves us forward then the s key
moves us backwards the a key moves us in
the right direction that we calculated
up here that's why we need it uh the d
key well the d key moves us in the
positive right direction and the a key
moves us in the negative right direction
so we go left essentially q and e will
just move us in the up direction and in
the down direction so q will go down
here and e will go up i'm actually not
sure q and e which one's supposed to go
up well whatever but either way
everything here sets moved to true so
that we know to recalculate everything
now we don't just need to recalculate
everything if we move using like the
wasd keys and the qe keys we also need
to recalculate everything if the mouse
rotates right so if we move the mouse
while holding the right mouse button
then we need to well rotate the view but
also mark moved as true so that we can
recalculate everything and that's what
happens over here so we work out how
much we're supposed to move in the pitch
and the yaw so the pitch is like our x
rotation so along the x-axis which is
our horizontal axis how are we rotating
so essentially rotating up and down
that's called pitch that obviously is
tied to the y kind of movement of the
mouse and when we move the mouse up and
down we would like to pitch up and down
now the your is going to be our x mouse
movement so moving from side to side
means that we your which is rotating
around the y axis hopefully this makes
sense it's kind of like an aircraft i
guess when you're moving an aircraft as
someone who used to fly planes this
makes sense to me but hopefully it also
makes sense to you it's quite common to
use like pitch and your to describe
camera rotation now then we have some
scary looking code here because we're
using a quaternion but basically all
this is doing is calculating a new
forward direction for us
by taking in the pitch and the your
delta into account so this quaternion
really just represents the delta of the
entire rotation so in all axes how much
did we rotate and then if we just rotate
the forward direction by that amount
we'll get a new forward direction which
is what's happening here we then mark
moved as true and if we have moved then
we do need to recalculate the view and
the ray direction so looking at
recalculated view that just builds up a
view matrix this line by the way is
completely unnecessary so we're using
lookout for that because that's probably
the simplest cleanest way to do this
we're basically saying that the camera
is at m positions this is the same as
that code that i removed earlier that
will translate it to position but then
the orientation of the camera is going
to be position plus forward direction so
kind of just giving it like a vector to
look at doesn't really matter if this is
like normalized or anything like that
and it doesn't matter if it's scale it's
just like hey you're over here look at
this coordinate please and that's what
the lookout function will do for us and
then we also have to specify an up
direction which is just going to be 0 1
0 and finally we're going to calculate
the inverse view by just inverting that
matrix and that's going to be useful to
us in the future now recalculate
projection is also a function that we
don't need to do here but if we do
resize the camera so we have a an on
resize function which you can see will
recalculate everything view technically
doesn't have to be recalculated i think
it's really just projection and ray
directions because that's gonna be based
on the projection and the view but since
view is just based on the position and
the forward direction which obviously
doesn't change we can get rid of this
recalculate projection will create a
perspective matrix for us based on a
field of view which uses this vertical
form over here the viewport width and
height to calculate the aspect ratio and
then also the near clip in the far clip
plane and then we'll just invert it to
get our inverse projection as well those
are like all of our matrices calculated
so now let's talk about the ray
directions which is really the last part
of this camera system as i mentioned
this ray directions is basically a
vector of vectors it's just going to be
our kind of cached calculations so we
have to do a bunch of math to figure out
ray directions from this like view and
projection matrix and you can see the
way we do that is we calculate that
negative one to one here as we did
before
so this code at the moment is pretty
much identical as you can see to what we
have in render a render but then we're
going to calculate a target by taking
the inverse projection and multiplying
it to this so interestingly what we're
doing here is we're actually going from
negative one to one space back into like
world space that's really what's
happening here for those of you familiar
with 3d graphics like using opengl or
directx or anything like that you know
that you have like a projection matrix a
view matrix a model matrix which is like
your transform and then like a vertex
position and usually in your vertex
shader what you will do is you'll take
that vertex position you'll multiply it
by the transform so that now you have
like the vertex position in a world
space because you've multiplied it by
the transform then you multiply that
with the view matrix and then the
projection matrix and obviously if
you're like in hlsl or in like row major
you'll do the opposite so left to right
your multiplication will be like vertex
position times transform times view
times projection versus something like
opengl or vulcan which uses column major
math mostly your glsl code will look
something like projection times view
times transform times vertex position
what that does is that takes us into
this kind of like normalized device
coordinates like clipping space which is
negative one to one that's what that
math does
here we know the normalized device
coordinates we know the negative one to
one because those are our pixels so what
we're trying to do is the opposite we
need to cast our ray in world space
but we have negative one to one so we
basically need to reverse this operation
we need to take everything and multiply
it by the inverse of each matrix and
also do a perspective division as you'll
see here in a minute to get us into
world space so what this is doing and
target is just really like our ray
direction it's just an intermediate
vector here but it's like where we're
targeting this vector so we have the
inverse projection times this coordinate
and then we're multiplying the inverse
view matrix by this target with a
perspective division that's been
normalized and that is now going to get
us into world space and then we can
simply cache that ray direction so this
kind of math over here is really the
reason why we're caching all of this
normalizing and this matrix
multiplication tends to take a little
bit of time on the cpu again normally
matrix multiplication should be fairly
quick if you're using simd because it
should be able to do it in way fewer
instructions however i don't know if glm
is using that here i don't know what you
guys are running so it's just safer to
cache this but when we do move this
exact code to the gpu and it runs inside
a shader whether that be a compute
shader or a ray tracing shader like a
rayjan shader that will just be very
very fast so there's absolutely no
reason to catch this in the future it's
just for now and i want to kind of
stress that okay cool so we've finally
gone over our camera class made some
adjustments let's talk about how we can
actually use this inside our code base
now so back in walnut app.cpp which is
really like the main kind of entry point
of our application we have this example
layer where we do everything everything
stems from here what we're going to do
is we're going to add a new function
here called on update and this is going
to be an override because it's going to
be something that we override from layer
specifically this on update function
make sure you update your walnut sub
module because this is a new addition so
let's put in that time step here and the
idea is we're just going to update our
camera here speaking of which let's
create a camera now i don't want to
create the camera inside the renderer
because the render i shouldn't really
own the camera i don't want the renderer
making decisions about where we render
our scene from that should be something
that we parameterize and pass in so in
other words when i actually call
renderer render over here i want to be
able to pass in a camera which will act
as a viewpoint to render from that way
if i want to render from like multiple
points of view or i want to move the
camera using some kind of like animation
or whatever that can all be external it
does not have to interact with the
renderer it just gives it a viewpoint to
render from so over here then inside our
layer is where i'm going to create that
camera now let's go ahead and include
camera
and then if we scroll down a little bit
more you'll see that we do need to
provide a vertical for veneer clip and
far clip and i'm going to do that over
here inside the constructor
so let's go ahead and write camera here
i'll write 45 degrees as my vertical
field of view that's a value i like
using near clip we'll leave it 0.1 and
far clip for now we'll set to 100 but we
might need to extend that in the future
those are fairly reasonable values okay
cool so our camera is set up let's make
sure that we update it by calling on
update with the time step every frame
over here and then going down into
renderer render i want to pass in that m
camera now as a side note i also need to
resize the camera so i'll just duplicate
this function and add in camera dot on
resize and then we're ready to render
with the camera so over here inside the
header file inside our renderer i'm just
going to pass in a camera it'll be const
camera reference camera like that we'll
be sure to include camera as well i'm
going to copy this and go to the
implementation paste it over here so
that we can access it and now basically
what we need to do as we loop through
every pixel here is just retrieve the
appropriate
cached ray direction because that should
already be there now what about the ray
origin well as you can see that's just a
fixed value so the ray direction is
really what changes per pixel the ray
origin you can see stays constant for
the for the whole image because our
camera is not moving in the middle of us
rendering our image in fact if we do
that we'll get some kind of tearing
because half the image will be from one
point of view and half the image will be
from the other so that's obviously not
what we want so basically what we can do
is we can get the camera position
outside of this for loop camera position
and in fact i'm going to name this our
array origin so that we kind of tie this
back into ray tracing and then the ray
direction which we can access with get
ray directions this is going to return a
vector for us right this returns a
vector and we'll need to provide an
index as to which ray direction we
actually want to access and that's going
to be our ray direction now this
obviously is going to be per pixel and
specifically it's just going to be the
pixel coordinate so x plus y times
our final image get width and that's
going to be our ray direction now that
means that we don't need this anymore
because we've already done that
calculation inside the ray directions
but it also means we have a slight
problem when it comes to our per pixel
function because that wants to take in a
coordinate that we've now gotten rid of
but that's okay what we're going to do
is refactor this a little bit we're
actually going to change this function
name to be called traceray instead i'm
going to go back to the header file make
sure that per pixel is changed into
traceray and over here as well so we've
just changed the name now but then i
also wanted to take in a ray instead of
taking in this vector coordinate now
what is array array is something that
has an origin and a direction so what
i'm actually going to do is go into our
solution explorer over here inside ray
tracing make sure i'll show all files
here under source i'm just going to add
a new item it's going to be a header
file called ray and this is just going
to be a very simple data structure here
that represents array so it's going to
be a struct called ray which will have
an origin
and a direction and that's it now we are
going to add some utilities to this file
in the future but for now we're just
going to write this and that's it going
back into our renderer header file i'm
going to include
this ray header file
and then that is going to be what we
pass into here
now we could pass it as const reference
it's 24 bytes of memory so it's probably
better to not copy it necessarily but
again that you know your mileage may
vary because it depends on the
architecture and everything and what the
compiler decides to do but we'll pass in
a constant ray over here that's going to
be our ray origin and ray direction so
we obviously have our ray origin and we
do have our ray direction so what i'm
going to do now is essentially construct
this instead of doing it here though
what i'm going to do is refactor this
code a little bit so that we actually
make the ray up here and then we can set
the origin to be the position up here so
we'll get rid of this and then the
direction we're going to set over here
so ray direction is what this is going
to become and then we're going to pass
the ray in like that in the future we
might actually change this to also kind
of act as like our rate cast struck so
in other words it will contain like
potentially a minimum and maximum
intersection distance and this is also
going to be basically exactly how we do
this when we move on to doing this like
all rtx style and ray tracing shaders
okay cool so there we go we have trace
ray it takes an array and returns a
color for us so let's go ahead and now
change this code so instead of using ray
origin array direction here we don't
need these anymore because we have our
array.direction so we can just add a
little dot here which is nice and ray
dot origin as well so going through our
code adding all of these things here
just fixing all of the errors and that
looks pretty good so now let's go ahead
and run this and see what happens
alright so we see an image much like we
do before that's good news and then if
we hold down the right mouse button and
just move the mouse you can see we can
actually move the camera and if i use
the wasd keys check this out i can
completely orbit around it and move
around
q and e will go up and down
i guess e should be going up because
that would be weird if q went up right
this feels more natural to me at least
but yeah you can see our render time has
slightly increased
especially when we like move but
otherwise it's still absolutely not bad
and still pretty interactive depending
on of course what resolution we make all
of this as well so yeah that's our
camera system so now we can actually
fully move around this sphere and see
that it is in fact 3d and this will be
super useful when we want to inspect
like obviously our scene and in fact i
mean at the moment we're rendering this
all in real time this will obviously
dramatically slow down depending on what
we're doing however we are going to also
implement some performance optimizations
run this on multiple threads and
eventually move it to the gpu so really
it won't probably won't matter too i
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
the ray tracing series if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
below as always all of this code will be
on github under a commit labeled episode
6 or whatever episode this is next time
i think we might take a look at how to
render multiple spheres because at the
moment we can just render one and we
might take a little bit of time to
customize the ui so that we can like add
and remove spheres position them using
imgui and do all that fun stuff thank
you all for watching definitely check
out brilliant in the description below
if you want to learn math and support
this series and i will see you next time
goodbye
you